bonjour Est-ce que vous avez la chance
de nous entendre j'ai presque envie de
dire est-ce qu'on aura la chance de vous
entendre également a priori
cette conférence va maintenant être
enregistrée
absolument que les choses fonctionnent
bonjour Bonjour Messieurs
Je la collègue à la délégation
sénatoriale aux outre-mer engage
aujourd'hui ainsi que d'audition sur les
pierres suicides d'évolution
institutionnelle dans l'objectif pour le
scénario est double d'une part de faire
un tour d'horizon des souhaits
d'évolution dans les territoires
ultramarins notamment exprimés mais pas
exclusivement dans l'appel de
Fort-de-France du 17 mai dernier et
d'autre part de mûrir la réflexion sur
une éventuelle révision des dispositions
constitutionnelles relative aux
outre-mer à l'occasion de l'élaboration
du prochain cadre institutionnel de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour cette réflexion
nous bénéficions du travail précurseur
du président Michel Magra qui a élaboré
en 2020 un rapport remarqué sur la
différenciation territoriale outre-mer
nous avons également recueilli
l'éclairage des éminents juristes de
l'ajdom lors d'un échange organisé le 29
juin dernier et dans les a qui ont été
publiés par notre délégation ils sont
d'ailleurs disponibles sur le site du
Sénat comme l'ensemble des comptes
rendus travaux de la délégation pour
notre premier audition nous accueillons
cet après-midi mon visioconférence
Monsieur Xavier Lédé président de la
collectivité territoriale de
Saint-Barthélémy monsieur le Président
nous vous remercions chaleureusement de
votre disponibilité puisque le décalage
horaire est le moins 6 heures et donc
11h30 chez vous je vais vous aider la
parole pour un exposé liminaire d'une
dizaine de minutes environ c'est pas un
exercice non plus imposé au niveau du
timing qui est consacré à cette
introduction sachant qu'un questionnaire
vous a été préalablement adressé pour
avoir une espèce de conducteur de cette
audition avec ma co-rapporteur Michel
Jack nous interrogerons ensuite en
premier lieu sur votre appréciation de
l'évolution institutionnelle de
Saint-Barthélémy depuis 2007 c'est à
dire en fait depuis le choix de la
collectivité régie par article 74 et
puis en second lieu votre approche sur
les perspectives d'évolution
constitutionnelle pour les outre-mer et
je doute pas que mes collègues auront
ensuite de nombreuses questions à vous
poser
ce Président vous avez la parole et bien
merci merci beaucoup de d'avoir organisé
cette audition je sais pas si je vais
vous faire 10 minutes ça risquerait de
faire redite un petit peu ensuite avec
le fil que le conducteur que vous m'avez
envoyé
néanmoins quoi vous dire que que
Saint-Barthélémy fait partie de ces
territoires où l'évolution a été la plus
importante certainement avec une
réussite derrière que l'on connaît donc
dans toute prétention nous avons
conscience que le modèle de Saint-Barth
va aussi servir d'exemple dans dans les
démarches qui sont entreprises
aujourd'hui et sur la possible révision
des articles 73 et 74
vous dire que tout ce travail ne peut
fonctionner qu'avec une population qui
adhère au projet avec un projet qui soit
clair n'était précis avec évidemment une
question de gestion des finances qui est
qui est indispensable et d'ailleurs
c'est la première la première compétence
qui est transférée dans le texte la loi
organique et la première mission qui est
confiée et que donc c'est vraiment tout
ce travail qui fait qu'aujourd'hui à
Saint-Barthélémy nous avons une
situation une évolution qui est bien
avancée qui n'est pas abouti il y a
évidemment des difficultés qui restent
alors que ce soit les compétences qui ne
seraient pas forcément transféré et qui
mériterait à minima d'être partagé que
ce soit les compétences qui ont été
transférées et qui n'ont pas forcément
été suivi d'effets on va dire plus en
termes administratif et en termes
d'accompagnement de l'État avec enfin
une difficulté aussi qui peut exister
lorsque des évolutions arrivent au
niveau de l'État et où alors en
particulier sur un territoire aussi
petit en termes de superficie
Saint-Barthélémy et bien ça passe un
petit peu à l'attrape et on peut être on
peut être oublié ou laisser de côté je
pense par exemple au PV électronique ou
aujourd'hui laisser les spécificités
pardon de Saint-Barthélemy longtemps été
pris en considération et nous mettent en
difficulté pour une mise en application
donc il y a vraiment un évidemment une
autonomie qui est indispensable un
travail d'adaptation à chaque territoire
qui est indispensable et là aussi on le
verra à travers certains exemples mais
un transfert de compétences qui se fait
en gardant une
un trajet on va dire par la Guadeloupe
puis par un ensemble
île du nord alors avec une une
dénomination en plus il est du Nord qui
ne fait plus forcément de sens dès lors
qu'on se détache de la Guadeloupe mais
bon ça ce n'est que de la sémantique
tout va-t-il arriver à Saint-Barthélémy
et bien nous avons déjà deux territoires
qui sont concernés avec chacun des
spécificités avec chacun des des
problématiques et des difficultés qui
leur sont propres et donc au final une
maîtrise de ce qui se passe à
Saint-Barthélemy qui n'est pas meilleur
que celle qu'on aurait dans un dans un
ministère ou dans un dans un bureau à
Paris et c'est vrai que de considérer
quand délocalisant sur les outre-mer on
a solutionné un problème en fait on
loupe une on loupe une étape et on ne
prend pas en considération le fait que
chaque territoire est bien spécifique et
c'est tout le sens de l'évolution et de
la fusion éventuelle et des articles 73
74 qui nécessitera donc aussi des
adaptations par rapport à
Saint-Barthélémy même si le travail est
déjà avancé bien avancé enfin une
dernière chose que je que je pourrais
dire c'est que tout ça mais aussi du
temps et qu'il doit y avoir une capacité
à imaginer à préparer un transfert mais
une capacité à s'adapter beaucoup plus
simple et beaucoup moins administrative
là aussi parce que les choses mettent du
temps donc de tout transférer du coup ça
n'est pas forcément toujours parce qu'on
ne peut pas tout faire en une semaine
évidemment et que donc il y a une
nécessité aussi d'être capable d'avoir
un travail qui soit progressif et une
projection sur plusieurs plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années pour avoir un
travail qui soit le plus efficace
possible mais je vous propose d'en
rester là en termes de présentation et
de et de rentrer plus dans le vif du
sujet et dans l'échange avec vous
bien volontiers effectivement puisque
l'essentiel sinon de ce que vous allez
dire finalement recoupe les questions
qu'on vous a adressez qui ne sont qu'une
trame évidemment il sera monsieur le
Président preneur d'une contribution
écrite si vous l'estimez nécessaire et
pertinente enfin voilà si vous souhaitez
nous adresser des éléments
complémentaires à cette audition ils
sont évidemment les bienvenus pour
étayer j'ai presque envie de dire c'est
d'ailleurs du reste ce qu'avait fait la
collectivité de Saint-Barthélémy en 2020
puisque nous avions reçu une
contribution écrite donc l'exercice il
est évidemment dans cette audition on
peut se dire des choses et vous avez
évidemment la possibilité de compléter
en tant que de besoin en fonction des
éléments qui vous viendra à l'esprit et
puis parce que tout simplement la
discussion aussi que nous allons avoir
peut amener d'autres réflexions si ça se
trouve qui n'ont peut-être pas vu encore
le jour ou des questionnements qui qui
peuvent nous interpeller j'en aurai une
d'ailleurs en lien avec les déclarations
du ministre d'outre-mer tout à l'heure
par rapport à l'objectif que le
gouvernement s'est fixé sur une possible
évolution institutionnelle outre-mer
on va pas reprendre les questions
intégralement puisque vous les avez sous
les yeux ça me paraît assez scolaire et
c'est pas forcément l'objectif
j'aimerais que vous fassiez aussi si
possible ce président un bilan un bilan
général des compétences que vous avez
que vous avez reçu par la loi et quelque
part un bilan de ce que vous avez pu
exercer ou moins pu exercer et pour
quelle raison de manière générale si
vous pouvez entrer dans le détail tant
mieux si vous restez sur les termes
généraux et génériques c'est aussi très
bien ça nous permet de comprendre
évidemment la sensibilité que vous avez
par rapport à ces transferts qui ont été
par exemple opérés
bien sûr je peux vous refaire la liste
éventuellement déjà rapidement de ce qui
est transféré par la loi organique donc
en reprenant l'article 62 14-3
donc la collectivité fixe les règles
applicables dans les matières suivantes
en termes comme je lisais tout à l'heure
d'impôt droit est un axe dans les
conditions prévues à l'article 74
-4 les compétences en matières
d'urbaniques
[Musique]
risque de construction d'habitation et
de logement la circulation routière est
transport routier des certes maritimes
etc la voirie le droit de manière elle
est bien de la collectivité
l'environnement y compris la protection
des espaces boisés l'accès au travail
des étrangers l'énergie le tourisme la
création et l'organisation des services
et des établissements publics de la
collectivité la location véhicule
terrestre d'un moteur donc voilà un
palais déjà de ce qui est de ce qui est
transféré si on les reprenait une par
une
certainement que le travail le plus
abouti sera comme je le disais la
première
la première la première matière
c'est-à-dire les impôts droits et taxes
parce que forcément tout transfert en
fait on parle souvent de transfert mais
tout transfert va aussi avec un
financement avec des dépenses et donc
des recettes et donc un transfert qui ne
serait pas
travaillé en amont avec une maîtrise de
la dépense ne pourrait pas marcher donc
nous avons aujourd'hui un code des
contributions qui est relativement
abouti même si il reste un travail à
faire sur le sur les modalités de
récupération et de contrôle de ces
différentes taxes pour vous donner juste
un exemple un sans entrer dans les
détails nous avons une contribution
forfaitaire annuelle des entreprises qui
existent ou aujourd'hui nous avons un
travail qui est en cours et ou sur les
titres à émettre sur les quatre
dernières années avec des
avec des majorations notamment nous
sommes aujourd'hui à plus de 4 millions
de titres à émettre ou environ 4
millions avec une liste qui n'est pas
forcément un jour donc il y a un travail
à faire mais tout ça pour dire qu'en
terme de récupération il nous reste un
il nous reste un travail à faire pour la
gouttière néanmoins on a une
collectivité qui est qui est saine et
j'aimerais dire même plus que celle en
termes de finance je vais pas vous
redonner le budget de la collectivité
ici son excédent mais je pense que notre
territoire est connu et reconnu pour la
santé de ses finances avec là aussi une
difficulté que nous aurons à travailler
c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est finance sont
basées essentiellement sur une forte
activité et sur une forte croissance
avec notamment la recette qui vient des
droitiers donc tous des toutes les
marchandises qui sont apportées et est
taxés sur le territoire et les recettes
qui viennent de la plus-value
immobilière donc en termes de droit de
quai si un moment ou un autre nous
devons contenir un petit peu ce
développement ce qui arrive forcément
parce que comme je le disais le
territoire n'est pas extensible et bien
le fait la recette droit de pin va se
réviser donc nous avons même si ça
fonctionne bien aujourd'hui une
nécessité d'être d'être dans la
perspective et de se projeter sur
d'autres ressources aux éventuelles un
modèle économique qui sera évidemment
pas changé mais qui a la marche peut
nécessiter une une visibilité et c'est
là aussi où la récupération des taxes
qui sont déjà installés
nécessitent un meilleur contrôle et une
meilleure capacité à récupérer parce que
nous n'avons pas vocation à aller
chercher des taxations supplémentaires
là où il n'y en a pas besoin avec un
budget qui est qui est déjà sain donc
vous voyez que même sur un sujet comme
celui-là qui est le je pense un des plus
aboutis il y a de toute façon un travail
qui reste à faire un travail aussi avec
avec l'état des fois sur les échanges de
fichiers notamment
nous avons par exemple aujourd'hui
une responsabilité à la collectivité de
faire des attestations de résidence
fiscale mais nous n'avons pas forcément
de d'échanges avec l'État donc nous
avons un système qui est en place ou
moyennant la fourniture de certains
documents la collectivité signe le
document avec un pétitionnaire qui
s'engage sur la justesse de ce qu'il a
été ce qui lui a été demandé néanmoins
là aussi la meilleure façon de garantir
et stabiliser notre notre compétence
fiscale c'est de pouvoir avoir un
contrôle et de s'assurer que notre
statut et notre système sont bien
utilisés et qui ne sont pas dévoyés par
certains donc il y a là-dessus un
travail que l'on doit aboutir avec avec
l'État nous avons une convention fiscale
qui n'a à ce jour jamais été signée donc
j'ai sollicité le ministre des Outre-mer
qui m'a dit qu'il était disposé à ce
qu'en fin nous puissions signer ce
document
voilà on a un travail aussi
d'explication à faire parce que dès
qu'on parle de fiscalité et de et de
Saint-Barthélemy on a tendance à avoir
un côté paradis fiscal etc ce qui n'est
pas du tout le cas et là aussi il faut
que chacun puisse prendre ses
responsabilités sans qu'une autre
territoire mais ça aussi l'état où on ne
peut pas être seul à travailler sur une
convention fiscale et seul à proposer
avec un état qui dit non non nous on ne
signe pas alors que ça fait partie des
documents qui sont qui sont prévus par
la loi aujourd'hui et qui doivent être
signés donc voilà sur sur ce sujet par
exemple il y a il y a un gros travail
l'urbanisme qui est le deuxième sujet
alors il y a il y a forcément un travail
un affinant qui sera revoir au fur et à
mesure bien malin celui qui pourrait
dire ce que serait la situation
aujourd'hui si nous n'avions pas
récupéré cette cette compétence
néanmoins j'ai tendance à considérer que
comme j'ai même si il y a des choses à
revoir nous sommes mieux protégés et
mieux la même de protéger notre
urbanisme parce que nous avons une là
aussi une spécificité vraiment locale
sur sur le sur le travail et sur la
vision du territoire donc il semble plus
que judicieux d'avoir une compétence
comme celle-là qui soit rapprochée de
Saint-Barthélemy et de la décision
locale néanmoins nous avons des parties
de notre code de l'habitation et de la
construction qui sont encore à rédiger
et c'est là où je disais on voit bien
que nous avons il y a un temps pour que
tout ça puisse se mettre en place et
qu'au final même si on peut faire un
retour d'expérience aujourd'hui il y a
aussi une réalité c'est que 2007 à
l'échelle d'une collectivité c'est hier
donc forcément il reste il reste du
travail et c'est là où je le redis il y
a un accompagnement et un travail commun
qui doit se faire sur sur ses évolutions
et je ne peux qu'une fois plus insister
sur la nécessité d'un accompagnement au
final pour vous prendre un autre exemple
nous avons récupéré la compétence en
matière de service incendie secours nous
avons un service territorial qui ne
dépend plus aujourd'hui du service
départemental de la Guadeloupe
sauf que les règles de fonctionnement
qui ont été adaptées à Saint-Barth
reprennent exactement ce qui se fait sur
un 10 or vous conviendrez contre un
territoire de 10 000 habitants et un
territoire de 400 000 habitants nous
n'avons pas les mêmes besoins donc il y
a là aussi un travail d'ajustement et
d'aménagement à faire à l'inverse là où
les compétences sont les mêmes c'est en
termes de gestion du personnel et là
aussi vous conviendrez que la gestion
d'un style c'est un peu particulier dans
dans une collectivité et dans un service
RH et le service RH de la collectivité
n'a pas du tout été accompagné donc
encore une fois les compétences elles
sont elles sont assumées elles sont
prises à leur accord mais c'est vrai que
ce manque d'accompagnement complique de
transfert de compétences nécessite que
les agents de même réussissent à se
former à aller chercher des informations
etc pour que ça puisse fonctionner le
mieux possible
en termes de circulation
c'est peut-être alors on n'a pas de on
n'a pas de compétences dont on dont on
souhaite se séparer je sais que c'est
une question qui revient plus tard mais
sur la circulation c'est peut-être celle
où j'ai envie de dire l'état c'est parce
que le plus débarrassé du bébé que qu'un
réel besoin de la collectivité donc ça
ça crée un ensemble de problématiques
qui n'ont pas été anticipées en termes
que je le disais par exemple tout à
l'heure le PV électronique en termes de
permis de conduire donc nous avons un
nous avons un permis de conduire qui est
local nous avons un code de la route qui
reprend le code de la route nationale
mais qui est aussi qui est aussi locale
le fait est que sur les personnes qui
souhaitent passer le code à
Saint-Barthélemy et la conduite en
métropole sacré les difficultés le fait
est qu'un permis local n'est pas
toujours reconnu
en métropole le fait est que sur les
transferts et les personnes qui arrivent
sur le territoire avec des permis qui
sont en et bien il y a les complexités
pour récupérer ce permis il y a aussi
des fois des abus avec des personnes qui
vont jouer sur deux permis et qui se
retrouvent suspendus en métropole sauf
que la formation ne suit pas forcément
et qui peut continuer de circuler etc
etc donc typiquement ça serait une des
une des compétences sur lesquelles on a
on a un sujet l'accès au travail des
étrangers on a aussi beaucoup de choses
à faire
alors là aussi c'est un sujet c'est un
sujet sensible mais typiquement sur un
territoire comme Saint-Barthélémy alors
je vais pas vous dire qu'on est dans la
situation de Mayotte ou d'autres îles
néanmoins nous là où la difficulté se
présente c'est que nous avons un
territoire qui est extrêmement petit et
nous avons une attractivité qui est
excessivement forte donc il faut qu'à un
moment un autre nous ayons moyens de
mieux cadrer l'accès au territoire alors
je sais que de mémoire c'était même un
gouvernement de gauche qu'il avait fait
à l'époque c'était quand le président
Mitterrand est arrivé au pouvoir mais
nous avions même la possibilité d'avoir
une fiche d'accès au territoire combien
même nous sommes sur un territoire
français pour s'assurer que quelqu'un
qui rentre à soit un billet retour soit
un contrat de travail un logement etc
pour s'assurer que voilà on ne se
retrouve pas dans les situations avec
des personnes qui au final viennent et
se retrouvent en difficulté sur le
territoire donc il y a il y a toute une
réflexion à mener sur une compétence
comme celle-là
en matière d'énergie évidemment alors
même si nous avons la compétence
nous travaillons avec EDF aujourd'hui
qui est alors je sais pas si c'est
encore complètement qui est globalement
une entreprise publique à 100% et donc
nous avons là aussi des liens forts et
un travail qui doit se faire de concert
avec avec l'État donc nous avons pris
la tâche de la Creuse nous sommes en
train de travailler sur
sur notre PPE qui n'est pas encore
rédigé donc voilà le travail se fait
même si typiquement sur ce sujet nous
avons du retard et nous avons aussi
d'autres responsabilité mais là encore
une fois voilà il y a il y a un travail
qui doit se faire en commun
et donc avec une situation aujourd'hui
qui est plutôt bonne à Saint-Barth et
les compétences qui ont été prises en
main néanmoins vous voyez que en
reprenant que qu'un ensemble d'exemples
et bien il y a des il y a les
difficultés et il y a un travail et je
vous dis un accompagnement au final dans
ce transfert qui des fois et a été a été
manquant
et à l'inverse monsieur le Président
est-ce qu'il y a des compétences que
vous
identifiez et qui serait mieux exercés
par votre collectivité qu'elle ne le
sont par l'État aujourd'hui par exemple
alors je vais je vais être un peu
méchant pour le coup si je caricaturé je
dirais que l'émission qui sont
toujours dépendantes de l'état de son
malheureusement pas très bien impliqué à
Saint-Barth mais de ce fait justement de
ce que j'isais au début de de se
dispatch entre la Guadeloupe les
territoires de Saint-Martin et de
Saint-Barthélémy et Saint-Barthélémy
derrière pour vous prendre un exemple
nous avons un rectorat aujourd'hui donc
qui est en Guadeloupe avec un vice
tracteur sur Saint-Martin et
Saint-Barthélemy mais au final tellement
de différence et de complexité qui
arrivait à Saint-Barthélémy et bien ça
patine toujours un peu alors notre
sénatrice qui est à vos côtés connaît
très bien ce sujet avec avec sa carrière
professionnelle et vous parlerez mieux
que moi les difficultés d'un chef
d'établissement à gérer une rentrée à
Saint-Barthélémy
mais voilà ce sont des ce sont des
compétences la compétence santé
également sur laquelle
le ministre des Outre-mer qui viennent
nous rendre visite passera par l'hôpital
et Vera par lui-même la situation
imaginez qu'à Saint-Barthélémy peut
ouprouve l'hôpital et le seul bâtiment
de Lille sur lequel aucun investissement
n'a été fait depuis le site premièrement
en 2017 et le seul bâtiment qui reste
partiellement détruit
alors que nous avons des besoins à
Saint-Barth et c'est juste un autre sens
et là je vais parler au nom de la
population mais c'est quelque chose
d'incompréhensible et là aussi l'État a
une mission à accomplir donc dans le
cadre du foncier nous sommes en train de
travailler pour régulariser la situation
ça fait partie de ces éléments
administratifs qui ont mis du temps à se
mettre en place parce que le transfert
de du foncier de l'hôpital a été prévu
et conventionné depuis 2008 et
aujourd'hui en 2017 nous sommes toujours
en train de travailler avec le
département pour pour y arriver mais
tout ça pour dire que oui on a une
situation en termes de santé ou je vais
pas vous dire que ce sont des
compétences que nous souhaitons
récupérer mais à minima nous devons
pouvoir les partager et nous devons
pouvoir rapprocher le
système décisionnaire de notre île parce
que voilà aujourd'hui on garde au final
sur ces compétences et bien ce fameux
millefeuille qu'on essaye d'éviter et
bien sur les compétences de l'État qui
partent cette répartition Guadeloupe
Saint-Martin Saint-Barthélémy et bien ça
fait nous avons des process
qui sont encore très longs et trop longs
et où la collectivité n'est pas assez
partie prenante à notre sens dans le
travail qui est à mettre en place
quelle appréciation vous portez sur tous
les dispositifs en fait qui permettent
de solliciter notamment les
habilitations adapter les normes dans
les domaines qui relèvent de la
compétence de l'État est-ce que pour
vous c'est fonctionnel est-ce que vous
avez déjà été amenés à solliciter ou
est-ce que ta dispositif qui n'a pas été
du tout actionné par la collectivité
ou depuis le début de mandat en tout cas
on n'a pas activé alors de mémoire ça
peut être fait quelquefois ça reste ça
reste long et long et complexe
c'est-à-dire que l'idée qui est un peu
celle qui se détache d'ailleurs de la
réécriture d'un article 74 ça serait
vraiment d'avoir un ensemble de
conférences de compétences qui soient
transférées pleinement ou partiellement
et où de manière simple une fois que
c'est tacté et bien la collectivité
directement avec le ministère concerné
ou avec la présidence de l'Etat et bien
nous pouvons acter de manière beaucoup
plus rapide que telle ou telle
compétence voilà on commence à
travailler dessus on la met en place etc
aujourd'hui ça reste
ça reste ça reste long et assez complexe
consultation préalable des collectivités
puisque j'étais président de la mienne
donc je pourrai aussi en parler mais je
laisserai mon président actuel mieux en
parler comment est-ce que vous vouliez
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est adapté
pour pour adapter par exemple à
législation au territoire saint-barthe
ou est-ce que c'est un dispositif qui
est soit obsolète ou il est pas
suffisamment respectueux par exemple des
délais nécessaires consultation des élus
et du temps nécessaire à travailler les
dossiers préalablement au passage de la
loi dans les hémicycles par exemple la
consultation se passe assez bien alors
pour reprendre le cas de Saint-Barth on
est sollicité par saisine le Conseil
exécutif et sollicité le conseil se
réunissant toutes les semaines ça ça
fonctionne relativement bien c'est
évident que s'il y a trop de dossiers
qui arrivent d'un coup et que le délai
est un peu court
j'ai envie de dire que plus que les élus
ce sont les services qui vont être
embêtés parce que vous vous doutez que
nous avons aussi les services qui
travaillent sur sur tous ces sujets donc
c'est évident que plutôt on peut être
saisi mieux c'est et globalement ça se
ça se passe plutôt bien
on a peut-être un manque sur le dès lors
que on a une proposition ou un avis
défavorable on a peut-être un manque un
petit peu sur le retour sur le retour
quand on a quand on ne se contente pas
de se dire à vie favorable sur la
saisine c'est peut-être à ce niveau là
qui pourrait y avoir une pour le coup
une navette supplémentaire un peu mieux
institutionnalisée pour avoir un retour
de ce qui a été entendu et fait suite à
la vie du conseil exécutif mais pour le
reste globalement à ce niveau là ça
fonctionne pas trop mal après c'est
certainement à nous et c'est un travail
qu'on a avec avec nos parlementaires et
qu'on va qu'on va encore appuyer de
s'assurer que certains textes pour
lesquels nous ne pas forcément saisi et
bien on puisse s'assurer que voilà il y
a un travail pour s'assurer que nos
territoires ne soient pas oubliés je
prenais l'exemple du PvE forcément il y
a un endroit quelque part dans les dans
les rouages où ça a buggé parce que je
ne veux pas imaginer que ce ne soit
qu'une question de surcoût de
développement de logiciel qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous soyons dans cette
cette situation donc il y a il y a
forcément quelque chose ou là je pense
qu'on pourra se mettre autour de la
table de manière plus
réduit pour voir comment s'assurer que
les territoires sont bien pris en
considération dans dans tous les textes
et dans toutes les évolutions notamment
dès lors qu'elles concernent les
compétences que nous n'avons pas
forcément
quand quand vous parlez de d'absence de
retour président sur des avis qui ne
seraient pas uniquement favorables à un
projet qui arrive sur votre bureau
est-ce que ça veut dire en réalité vous
n'avez pas de retour ou pas de prise en
considération de cet avis modifié par le
gouvernement oui pas de retour
concrètement là depuis depuis avril
quasiment toutes les semaines nous avons
des saisines alors je vais quand même je
vérifié qu'on était service après que
c'est à notre niveau qui a un retour et
une transmission de la formation qui ne
se fait pas
mais je n'ai jamais eu un retour sur la
délibération du conseil exécutif qui est
la vie du conseil exécutif qui est
renvoyé pour avoir ne serait-ce que un
accusé de réception et de dire ok nous
vous avons bien pris note et un retour
de texte à demander ou non par la suite
ok
au niveau de l'organisation président
est-ce que vous dans l'organisation
actuelle des règles de fonctionnement de
la collectivité vous voulez considérer
plutôt comme satisfaisante parce que
vous avez eu des points de blocage et
une question qui m'intéresse dans le
parallèle avec une autre collectivité
que je connais assez bien est-ce que le
Saint-Barthélémy a la possibilité de
saisir juge administratif pour
l'interprétation de la loi organique où
est-ce que c'est seulement le préfet
comme à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
il faudrait que là j'avoue que j'ai pas
là j'ai pas la réponse il faudrait que
je vérifie sur ce point là je sais pas
si Olivier toi tu as le cas mais on
vérifiera
en réalité à saint-pierre-et-miquante
tel que c'est rédigé seul le préfet peut
saisir l'administratif de
l'interprétation de la loi organique
[Musique]
sur un texte mais dès lors que pour
imaginer une formule soit que le
Président le Conseil exécutif puisse
saisir pour vérifier
la lecture d'un article soit
éventuellement qu'un nombre de un nombre
de conseillers puissent aussi saisir
pour éviter un blocage qui serait fait
par le président le conseil donc d'avoir
cette alternative aussi de x% de des
élus qui puisse qu'ils puissent saisir
le tribunal
et enfin pour ma partie et puis après la
parole à Micheline sur la seconde partie
mais on pourra continuer avec des
questions de nos collègues bien
évidemment
comment vous juger l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement l'État pour exercer les
compétences qui ont été transférées je
pense que vous aviez commencé à
l'évoquer
est-ce que les transferts se sont bien
déroulés est-ce qu'il y a d'ailleurs eu
un bilan conjoint qui a été opéré entre
l'État et la collectivité sur ce point
et pour vous la déconcentration de
l'État permet-elle suffisamment
d'adapter les règles propres à
s'appliquer à votre territoire je pense
qu'effectivement c'est là où j'allais
lire une défaillance et c'est peut-être
un peu fort comme terme mais c'est là où
au final les choses n'ont pas toujours
été suivies donc je vous ai repris
quelques exemples je vais pas les
reprendre mais où il y a vraiment cette
nécessité que les services de l'État
puissent être aussi adaptés aux
compétences qui ont été transférées pour
s'assurer que voilà les spécificités
soient bien soient bien comprise que les
logiciels parfois soit bien adapté et
donc il y a il y a eu des fois un manque
à ce niveau là après j'ai envie de dire
que quand on saisit les services de
l'État il y a pas forcément de souci les
les services répondent dans la mesure de
leurs moyens et à ce niveau-là un
accompagnement se fait il y a pas de
problème mais c'est vraiment plus dans
la technicité des fois où il y a eu des
il y a eu des loupés et après en termes
de de décentralisation comme je vous
lisais malheureusement il y a certains
services ou tant qu'on passe par un
système Guadeloupe illumer
Saint-Barthélemy et bien ça n'est pas
assez fonctionnel parce que en termes en
termes de budget c'est pas toujours
évident je prenais le cas de l'école
tout à l'heure
je vais vous prendre un exemple concret
mais un enseignant qui fait sa demande
de mutation fait une demande sur
l'académie de Guadeloupe
imaginer que l'enseignant qui fait sa
demande de mustation parce que Monsieur
ou Madame a été nommé aux Abymes pour
travailler et se retrouve limité à
Saint-Barthélémy ce n'est pas le même
projet de vie et ça pose forcément des
problèmes à l'inverse l'enseignant qui
souhaiterait venir à Saint-Barth en
ayant conscience de toutes les
difficultés qui peut y avoir à
Saint-Barth et qui se retrouvent nommé à
moule là aussi ce n'est pas le ce n'est
pas le même projet de vie donc il y a il
y a des il y a les adaptations à mettre
en place et sortir de cette idée que au
final Guadeloupe Martinique Saint-Martin
Saint-Barthélemy c'est peu ouprou la
même chose nous sommes sur une zone
géographique qui est qui est proche nous
avons des liens qui sont qui sont forts
notamment avec avec Saint-Martin et avec
avec la Guadeloupe de par notre histoire
administrative et pas que parce que
beaucoup d'habitants de Saint-Barth ont
pu faire leurs études à Saint-Martin ou
en Guadeloupe aujourd'hui nous avons des
échanges très réguliers avec la
collectivité de Saint-Martin
néanmoins ça n'enlève rien au fait que
on peut s'appuyer les uns sur les autres
pour voir les problématiques qui sont
qui sont rencontrées pour voir notamment
dans le cadre de compétences transférées
et bien ce qui fonctionne chez les uns
et pas chez les autres avant de avant de
passer sur un transfert de compétences
ou de voir comment adapter un transfert
de compétences pour éviter les écueils
que les uns ou les autres ont pu avoir
mais nous sommes sur les territoires qui
sont au final quand même très différents
et avec des problématiques très
différentes et donc cette
décentralisation qui est au final
partielle ne change pas grand chose
parce que comme je vous lisais au début
passé par Pointe-à-Pitre ou passer par
Paris ce n'est pas très différent en
terme de maîtrise du sujet
merci président comme la rappeler notre
président stefana qui je rend hommage
aussi pour sa grande expérience tant
qualité de président une collectivité
que la présidence de la délégation nous
avons engagé ces travaux en vue
d'actualiser le rapport de Michel Magra
et notamment pour vérifier la lésion
assez préconisations comme vous le savez
la proposition de réécriture des
dispositions outre-mer de la
Constitution est en quelque sorte le
cœur du rapport quel est votre avis sur
une éventuelle fusion des articles 73-74
de la Constitution et la fin de la
dichotomie historique
j'ai envie de dire que c'est presque une
question qu'il faudrait retourner au
retourner au Sénat parce que c'est vrai
que vous avez vu cette cette vraie
maîtrise technique on va dire de ces
articles le encore une fois comme je
l'ai dit le la refonte d'un article
global et l'idée d'avoir vraiment des
compétences spécifiques et des statuts
spécifiques à chaque territoire me
semble indispensable le
la distinction qui est faite entre le
principe d'identité législative et la
spécialité législative
j'ai envie de dire qu'un
Saint-Barthélémy on montre de fait que
cette distinction elle est elle est
obsolète sur le territoire parce que
nous avons les compétences et donc des
des réglementations et des sanctions à
mettre en place et en même temps nous
dépendons aussi de aussi de l'état donc
cette distinction qui qui au final et
pour moi très administrative elle n'est
plus elle n'est plus justifiée sur sur
un territoire comme de l'autre et c'est
deux principes en aucun cas ne peuvent
être bloquants et cette distinction
comme je vous dis elle est pour moi elle
n'est plus adaptée à des territoires et
en tout cas un autre territoire en
particulier je laisserai chaque
élu parlé pour pour son territoire mais
je pense que voilà
sur ces spécificités on est au bout de
cette distinction
bien entendu que c'est le travail du
législateur mais si nous auditionnons
les les exécutifs c'est justement pour
savoir exactement où il se situe puisque
nous avons des collectivités qui sont
régies par l'article 73 autres par
l'article 74 et à travers ces deux
articles chaque collectivité disposent
de spécificités législatives
particulières donc
le pneu du le principal point du rapport
de Michel c'était justement de pouvoir
proposer une fusion de ces articles avec
des statuts à la carte pour chaque
territoire qui serait chaque statut
serait régie par une organique donc le
but de la question c'était de faire part
de votre expérience sur la collectivité
de Saint-Martin lui pour pouvoir
justement nous éclairer et éclairer
les autres collègues
c'est pour ça et c'est le sens ma
question c'était plus lui dire au sens
aujourd'hui du Sénat par exemple
qu'est-ce qui justifierait le principe
de spécialité législatives et comme je
vous le dis on le voit à
Saint-Barthélemy avec des compétences
qui de toute manière n'ont pas vocation
être transféré ou transféré pleinement
on aura toujours cette dichotomie qui va
qui va exister donc il y a une nécessité
de pouvoir avoir cette avoir cette au
final cette hybride aujourd'hui et je
pense que c'est le sens de la refonte de
l'article 74 et en parallèle comme je
vous dis notamment notamment en termes
de facilité d'accès à tout cela d'avoir
une capacité à agir au fur et à mesure
sans repasser par tout un process
administratif
donc si l'article 74 de la Constitution
devait être écrit quel serait les
dispositions que vous souhaitez auriez
voir Modifier lesquels sont un point de
blocage pour les évolutions statutaires
que vous souhaiteriez
aujourd'hui on a notamment sur tout ce
qui est les sanctions pénales entre
autres on est on est limité on est
limité avec avec malgré tout des
situations
financières sur Saint-Barthélémy qui
sont qui sont bien spécifiques et donc
dans le dans le fonctionnement actuel
nous avons une des plafonds qui sont mis
en place je vais vous prendre alors on
va rentrer dans les choses très très
concrètes et très simple donc ils
peuvent paraître anecdotiques mais en
termes de gestion de nuisances sonores
comment imaginez-vous qu'un touriste qui
loue une villa à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros la semaine réagit si
vous venez lui mettre une amende de 35
ou 75 euros en fonction du niveau
sauf que la collectivité aujourd'hui est
bloquée sur certains éléments comme
celui-là en termes d'environnement on
l'a vu avec avec toi même à Micheline
quand nous travaillons sur le club de
l'environnement où on se retrouve avec à
chaque fois une possibilité de mettre
des amendes administratives mais en même
temps un plafond de verre qui ne peut
pas être dépassé là où au final c'est
pareil aujourd'hui avec des taux
d'amandes qui sont parfois trop bas et
bien le côté dissuasif de l'amande est
perdue donc il faut qu'il puisse y avoir
une adaptation dans ces textes et
laisser une une marge de manœuvre plus
grande notamment sur les catégories
d'amende qui puissent être remise en
place au niveau de au niveau de la
collectivité donc je vous ai pris deux
exemples on pourrait le on pourrait le
reprendre sur quasiment chaque
compétence de la collectivité
quel sens donnez-vous à la notion
d'autonomie notamment en ce qui concerne
la relation avec l'État
alors la notion d'autonomie je sais pas
si j'ai une vision particulière de ce
sujet mais j'ai souvent tendance à dire
que la meilleure manière d'être autonome
c'est de laisser faire chacun ce qu'il
peut faire et ce qu'il fait bien donc
l'autonomie pour moi c'est effectivement
de réconférer on a parlé dans l'ensemble
de compétences donc ce que la
collectivité peut faire et bien faire
nous avons vocation à le récupérer par
contre nous avons aussi vocation et nous
avons une attache profonde à
Saint-Barthélémy au territoire au
territoire français à la nation donc
nous avons par exemple un sujet sur le
transfert de compétences sociales
évidemment un tel transfert de
compétences ne veut pas dire que
Saint-Barth veut se dissocier de l'État
et de ne pas participer à un effort de
solidarité nationale ça va le ça va le
soir mais voilà il y a dès lors qu'une
compétence n'est pas bien établie et
n'est pas bien mise en place alors que
nous nous pourrions le faire avec toute
prétention mieux alors c'est là où cette
autonomie doit se mettre en place mais
cette autonomie passe aussi comme je
vous le dis par un lien fort avec avec
l'État et où l'État a démission nous
n'avons pas vocation à récupérer mais où
nous devons être partenaire là aussi
j'avoue que j'ai pu être choqué sur
certains échanges que j'ai eu ou souvent
on oppose état et collectivités alors on
a eu des des situations où sur les des
mutations ou autre on nous dit ben non
parce qu'il doit y avoir des périodes de
carence etc comme si quelqu'un qui avait
travaillé pour l'État
n'était pas l'état fiable pour
travailler en collectivité ou comme si
l'inverse était vrai aussi je pense que
vous avez le cas de quelqu'un
aujourd'hui qui travaille au Sénat et à
qui on a demandé ce que je peux entendre
dire mais reste à l'écart des travaux
qui concernent Saint-Barthélemy alors
que pour moi on se prive au final plus
de quelqu'un qui a une maîtrise du
territoire
sur sur un système qui je ne comprends
pas bien à quel moment on se base sur un
système où on dit que l'État et les
territoires sont en opposition nous
sommes partenaire et l'autonomie pour
moi passe par une vraie notion de
partenariat et non pas par une
opposition de l'un et l'autre et
j'insisterai aussi grandement sur le
fait que l'autonomie n'est pas
l'indépendance parce que souvent
évidemment pas au Sénat mais on a on a
un mélange des gens qui se fait quand on
utilise un ou l'autre de ces termes et
évidemment lorsque nous demandons à
Saint-Barthélémy plus d'autonomie et de
récupérer certaines compétences à aucun
moment je pense dans la tête de quelques
citoyens de notre territoire que ce soit
il y a une volonté d'indépendance du
territoire qui serait à mon sens en tout
cas complètement aberrant
l'article 74 de la Constitution permet
aux collectivités dotées de l'autonomie
d'adopter des mesures justifiées par les
nécessités locales en matière d'accès à
l'emploi de droit d'établissement pour
l'exercice d'une activité
professionnelle ou de protection du
patrimoine français comme c'est le cas à
Saint-Barthélémy souhaitez-vous aller
plus loin voyez vous d'autres domaines
dans lesquels les mesures de protection
de la population vous semble justifier
sur déjà sur les sujets qui sont qui
sont évoqués comme j'ai pu le dire tout
à l'heure nous avons un territoire
qui est relativement restreint en termes
de superficie une attractivité qui est
extrêmement forte et on a pu le voir à
deux reprises en 95 après le passage du
cyclone Luis où nous étions encore une
commune de du département Guadeloupe et
en 2017 après le passage de l'ouragan
Irma ou à chaque fois la reconstruction
a créé un appel d'air donc on voit bien
que le système qui a été mis en place et
le système de collectivité territoriale
mais sur ce point précis n'a pas changé
la donne parce que nous avons eu
exactement les mêmes écueils exactement
les mêmes difficultés avec un afflux de
personnes certes nécessaires pour
reconstruire pour reconstruire vite mais
au final aussi un établissement de
nombreuses personnes de nombreuses
sociétés qui a accentué les difficultés
en termes de logement qui a accentué les
difficultés en termes de
d'insalubrité et de salubrité avec des
établissements qui sont parfois
surchargés des logements qui sont
surchargés donc tout ça c'est lié à la
construction et en même temps comme je
dis on a une forte attractivité et
un tourisme qui marche extrêmement bien
donc là aussi sur les établissements
hôteliers mais nous avons une forte
demande en termes de personnel et donc
avec un cadrage qui est assez faible au
final et des moyens assez faibles pour
vérifier ce qui se passe et bien nous
avons nous avons des difficultés donc
déjà sur ces sujets il est il est
indispensable que nous puissions aller
encore plus loin et ça va un petit peu
dans le sens de ce que je disais il y a
il y a quelques instants en termes de
maîtrise de l'accès au territoire de
main d'oeuvre étrangère etc etc sachant
que par manoeuvre étrangère
malheureusement à Saint-Barthélémy on a
tendance à imaginer toute personne qui
n'est pas déjà installée sur le
territoire alors je sais bien que nous
avons une libre circulation que ce soit
déjà sur le territoire français parce
que la personne français et aussi en
Europe
néanmoins il y a une nécessité je pense
pour l'état de prendre en considération
les spécificités des territoires comme
les nôtres qui sont qui sont extrêmement
petits en termes de place donc sur sur
ces points déjà avant même le penser à
autre chose nous avons un travail à
faire pour pour améliorer la situation
je pense
donc
le point des suivants la question
suivante vous en avez vous l'avez déjà
un peu évoqué toujours au titre de la
collectivité dotée de l'autonomie ça m'a
artelémy participe à l'élection des
dispositions pénales en cas d'infraction
règles fixée par la collectivité plus
généralement l'article 74 de la
Constitution prévoit la possibilité pour
la collectivité de participer sous le
contrôle de l'État à l'exercice des
compétences qu'il concerne dans le
respect des garanties des garanties
accordées sur l'ensemble du territoire
national pour l'exercice des libertés
publiques quelle analyse faites-vous de
ce dispositif
c'est effectivement c'est un peu ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure et c'est
malheureusement certainement le plus dur
dans l'histoire mais c'est que ça ne
fonctionne pas tant que tant que nous
avons
tant que nous avons autant de autant de
niveaux pour prendre une décision et
pour mettre en application des règles ça
ne fonctionne pas nous avons alors je
les ai pas ramené là nous avons
plusieurs plusieurs délibérations qui
ont aussi être prises pour vous donner
un autre exemple lors des différentes
mandatures précédentes et où au final il
n'y a pas eu de suivi il y a pas une
mise en application donc on a vraiment
besoin de réussir à rapprocher le
système de décision de la collectivité
encore une fois dans un dans un esprit
qui est pour moi celui de la des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen qui est-ce qui
doit évidemment prévaloir après au
niveau au niveau état et bien il nous
devons adapter autant que possible et
dès que possible sur sur tous ces sujets
mais effectivement je vais pas
re-développer on en a parlé redévelopper
plus longuement
ensuite je terminerai mes questions la
population à dire telle à ce statut de
collectivité d'outre-mer des souhaits
d'évolution s'expriment-ils dans le
débat public qu'en est-il des
socioprofessionnels et enfin une
possible révision constitutionnelle
suscite-t-elle des inquiétudes ou des
espoirs
alors oui le l'évolution l'évolution
fait évidemment partie des sujets et
notamment celui des socioprofessionnels
parce que comme on l'a dit le modèle de
Saint-Barth est fondé sur une économie
très forte et un tissu économique très
fort donc oui tout ça ça fait partie des
sujets les souhaits d'évolution sont
derrière ce que je ce que je vous dis là
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas sorti de mon
chapeau et et vu tout seul et oui
clairement voilà aujourd'hui après c'est
2007 2022 c'est 15 ans de ces 15 ans
d'évolution et bien voilà on est quand
même capable de faire en retour et de
voir un ensemble de choses qui ne
fonctionnent pas ou qui ne fonctionne
pas assez bien et qui nécessite
qui nécessite une évolution
en termes en termes d'enjeux de
démocratie locale voilà c'est encore une
fois de d'impliquer d'impliquer le plus
possible tout le monde de donner de la
marge de manœuvre à tout le monde pour
travailler encore une fois comme je le
disais juste avant le le cadre qui
existe c'est le cadre des droits de
l'homme et évidemment Saint-Barth n'a
pas vocation à faire quoi que ce soit
qui n'irait pas dans le dans le sens du
bien-être du bien vivre et de
l'épanouissement de chacun ça c'est une
certitude
enfin en termes de
en termes de révision de la Constitution
inquiétude il y a forcément toujours une
inquiétude parce que nous avons un
statut qui est qui est particulier et à
fortiori dans le la composition du des
parlements aujourd'hui il y a une
interrogation maintenant moi je reste
conscient et convaincu que le statut de
Saint-Barthélemy c'est ni quelque chose
qui était volé ni un cadeau qui était
fait à la population et que donc les
acquis n'ont pas de raison être remis en
question là où je lisais tout à l'heure
le travail que nous avons à faire c'est
de montrer que justement nous on
travaille pour que ces acquis
bénéficient à ceux qui le méritent entre
guillemets et pas à des personnes qui
voudraient profiter d'un système
maintenant il y a aussi effectivement un
espoir dans un dans une modification de
la Constitution
un ou l'autre j'aurais envie de répondre
les deux les deux en général oui il y a
évidemment des inquiétudes qui existent
mais aussi des attentes pour pouvoir
adapter encore plus le statut de notre
territoire assez spécificités
je vais en terminer si Micheline pardon
on est d'accord avant de donner la
parole à mes collègues j'ai une question
en fait une incidence qui fait qu'au
propos qui ont été tenus au repas à
l'Élysée par différents intervenants et
notamment le gouvernement et le ministre
qu'un co qui évoque pour lui
l'importance de création de valeur dans
nos territoires donc la question que je
pose c'est est-ce que le statut actuel
de Saint-Barthélémy vous permet de créer
de la valeur sur votre territoire et si
c'est le cas malgré tout mais un
tiendrait et vous une demande
d'adaptation du statut à la marge donc
on a bien compris qu'il y a peut-être
pas nécessité de bouleversement majeur
mais plutôt peut-être d'adaptation d'un
certain nombre de dispositions dans ce
cadre là
alors oui il y a de la valeur qui est
créée sur le territoire il y a
effectivement il y a certainement là un
travail d'adaptation à mettre en place
parce que nous avons les structures qui
ne sont pas forcément extrêmement
importantes et donc il faut adapter les
volumes à ce qui peut se faire à
sabarque là où nous pouvons avoir une
difficulté c'est la valeur en termes de
en termes d'image j'ai envie de dire ou
le statut crée une difficulté c'est en
termes de formation c'est-à-dire que on
peut tout à fait imaginer que des jeunes
de notre îles souhaitent se former et je
vais vous reprendre l'exemple de
l'éducation qui est très simple un jeune
de Saint-Barthélémy qui souhaite se
former pour devenir enseignant du
secondaire va devoir partir se former à
l'extérieur jusque là pas de problème il
a il obtient ses diplômes il va être
nommé sur un premier poste ce premier
poste ne se fera pas Saint-Barthélémy
dès lors qu'il est nommé Horse de
Saint-Barthélemy il perd sa résidence
fiscale donc voilà typiquement un
élément sur lequel qui pourrait se
régler par le biais d'une convention
fiscale qui nécessite pas forcément une
révision de la Constitution mais qui
nécessite une convention fiscale qui
soit adaptée donc en termes de création
de richesse j'ai envie de lire que alors
que nous avons une population qui est
qui est volontaire et je vais pas je
vais pas vous dire qu'à Saint-Barth on
se forme pas du tout mais par contre on
se bloque et on se contraint sur
certains postes en amplifiant une
problématique qui est celle de du
logement parce que ne créant pas et ne
formant pas sur certains
métiers spécifiques nous sommes obligés
de faire venir de l'extérieur des
personnes qui ne sont pas logées et donc
voilà c'est un peu un cercle vicieux et
typiquement voilà là une limite à la
création de richesse sur notre
territoire
pour ceux et celles qui voudraient
prendre la parole et poser des questions
n'oubliez pas d'allumer votre micro
puisque c'est enregistré donc je regarde
mes collègues qui pourraient souhaiter
intervenir
Nassima Nadar
oui merci à vous parce que je trouve
très intéressant la présentation qui a
été faite pourquoi parce que il y a
beaucoup de peur ou d'appréhension par
rapport à justement les deux articles
sur la fusion du 73 et du 74 et c'est
vrai que même pour nous parlementaire
les choses ne sont pas aussi claires
puisque le 74 ne
le 73 peut permettre des adaptations le
74 donne plus d'autonomie et j'aime bien
la définition que vous avez donné
la véritable définition de l'autonomie
c'est dire que un territoire peut faire
et ce qu'il fait bien et que et que ce
qui manque me semble-t-il si j'ai bien
entendu ce que vous venez de nous
expliquer ce qui manque parfois c'est le
partenariat avec les services de l'État
donc comment arriver à avoir de
l'autonomie mais avec un partenariat
avec les services de l'État qui qui
tiennent vraiment et qui pourraient être
établi à partir de règlement
enfin voilà c'est peut-être aussi le
travail que nous devons faire au Sénat
et donc moi j'avais une question sur la
valeur
la création de valeur
est-ce que selon vous il y a une
différenciation entre la création de
valeur individuelle pour chaque citoyen
et la
création de valeur collective donc
est-ce que le 74
a-t-il créé une différenciation entre
la création de valeur individuelle pour
le citoyen de de
Saint-Martin ou de Saint-Barth par
exemple les deux collectivités et la
création de la valeur collective et
quand je dis collective je garde la
France c'est-à-dire la République
française puisque les territoires même
régie par l'article 74 reste pleinement
des territoir pouvoir de la France
républicaine
oui oui il y a une différence en même
purement mathématique c'est très
clairement si on prend la somme des
valeurs et des richesses créées par les
individus elle ne supérieure au final à
ce qui va être la valeur créée par le
territoire à mon sens alors déjà du fait
qu'on est aussi une
internationalisation on va dire de notre
économie donc il y a un fait là dessus
et là-dessus je pense qu'on a aussi un
travail à faire pour voir quand je
parlais de quand je parlais de
l'importance d'avoir une un système d'un
système de finance qui soit fort et qui
fonctionne sur le territoire pour que ça
marche je disais aussi qu'on a besoin
d'adapter aujourd'hui pour ne pas être
entièrement dépendant ou trop dépendant
d'un développement économique donc il y
a une il y a une marge de manœuvre à
trouver à ce niveau là pour s'assurer
que la richesse qui est créée par tous
sur le territoire est-ce bien elle
bénéficie à tous sur le territoire
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas complètement le
cas alors ce qui pourrait être vrai en
métropole aussi j'ai envie de lire avec
le bémol près que les échanges sont
beaucoup plus fréquents entre on va dire
la France et les États-Unis contre si je
prends le cas du Portugal par exemple
nous avons une forte communauté
portugaise à Saint-Marc évidemment la
richesse qui est créée par des
ressortissants portugais et qui est
exporté sur le Portugal n'est pas
compensé par une richesse créée par des
saint-barthes ou des Portugais au
Portugal et importer à Saint-Barthélémy
donc de ce fait là la richesse du
territoire et la valeur du territoire et
inférieure à mon sens à ce qui est créé
sur l'ensemble du territoire
par exemple
et après juste pour rebondir donc on
parlait d'autonomie pour vous donner un
exemple
de la responsabilité que chacun doit
prendre et là où je vais malheureusement
un petit peu tapé sur les doigts de
l'État c'est je vais vous reprendre un
exemple très concret qu'on a eu il y a
quelques semaines et qui pour le coup je
vais donner ce crédit au préfet il a
fait se fâcher tout rouge on va dire
c'est que nous avions une présentation
des services de l'État qui ne sont pas
présent à Saint-Barth qui sont soit
Saint-Martin sont en Guadeloupe et qui
sont censés appliquer leur mission sur
le territoire et nous avions un
représentant de la douane qui nous a
expliqué qu'il ne venait pas à
Saint-Barth parce que ça coûte trop cher
vous comprendrez bien que et nous élu de
la collectivité et pour le coup Monsieur
le Préfet qui qui a commencé aussi sa
mission sur nos territoires en avril
nous sommes restés stockés d'une telle
réponse d'autant plus que la
collectivité joue le jeu et que nous
mettons à disposition des logements des
véhicules des repas éventuellement pour
les différents services de l'État ce qui
n'est pas notre mission nous n'avons pas
faire mais nous jouons le jeu autant que
possible pour que ces missions puissent
être accomplies donc quand on entend une
personne nous répond ça sans même avoir
sollicité pour venir et savoir si tout
va être fait
le bémol c'est que l'étape d'après c'est
pour revenir avec un maître-chêne ils
nous ont demandé d'affriter un avion
voilà il faut il faut qu'on trouve aussi
un juste milieu mais mais voilà où on a
on a des fois les difficultés et où il
faut que nous puissions aussi avoir ce
dialogue pour que chacun fasse et fasse
bien ce qu'il a à faire sur le
territoire
je disais que effectivement si on
comprend bien pour que ça marche pour
que ça fonctionne véritablement c'est
bien les conditions du partenariat avec
l'État et des grands services plutôt
régaliens qu'il faut réajuster
et transférer complètement et pleinement
ce qui est ce qu'il a déjà été fait dans
au niveau administratif et je vais je
vais soumettre dans le prolongement
avant de donner la parole à Lana
pour rejoindre ce que vient de dire
Nassima et vous monsieur le Président
dans ce cadre-là on pourrait aussi
imaginer ou réfléchir à la manière dont
le niveau constitutionnel pour y
garantir
cette cette relation entre la
collectivité et l'État puis derrière la
loi organique de quelles conditions
elles le font c'est d'ailleurs ce que du
reste que Michel Magra avait déjà évoqué
à l'époque notamment sur sur les normes
entre autres donc c'est vrai que c'est
sans doute un mécanisme peut-être
qui qui permettrait de garantir
effectivement cela
si vous voulez je peux vous lire en
extrait justement du rapport de Michel
Magra sur les normes où il disait que
l'efficience passe par une meilleure
adéquation en réalité par une
contextualisation des mesures et donc
par une nécessaire différentiation
territoriale autrement dit il s'agit de
faire en sorte qu'aucune orientation
uniforme ne s'impose à tout l'ensemble
des outre-mer par tous les tatouage
accompagner les collectivités
territoriales pour nourrir leurs
capacité propre d'expertise et leur
garantir une véritable autonomie
qu'elles peuvent mettre en service de
leur développement endogène c'est la clé
pour réussir une planification
stratégique et opérationnelle efficace
donc
vous nous avez je voulais vous remercier
vraiment parce que vous nous avez bien
éclairé sur des termes
à redéfinir pour nous-mêmes parce que
autonomie partenariat
régalien avec la présence de l'État et
en réalité il manque vraiment du lien et
même du réglementaire
sur la relation état avec avec la
collectivité autonome donc c'est bien
si je devais résumer en quelques mots
j'irai simplement qu'il faut faire
confiance alors j'avais faite nous
confiance d'une manière générale faites
confiance au territoire dès lors qu'il y
a dès lors qu'il y a un projet qui
éclaire une on va dire encore une fois
le projet de société le projet
économique dès lors que ça c'est clair
et dès lors qu'il y a une forte adhésion
derrière vous savez à pas de il y a pas
de mystère j'avais regardé à
Saint-Barthélémy en lorsque le lorsque
le référendum a eu que nous avons eu
soit plus de 78% de participation et un
vote pour à 95,7%
. j'ai envie de lire que dès lors que
voilà on a cette adhésion et que il y a
cette volonté il ne faut il ne faut pas
voir les collectivités et l'État comme
comme opposé ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas de
sens faites confiance il y a un terme
que j'aime pas beaucoup qui est celui du
sachant
mais en l'occurrence sur les territoires
les sachants ils sont sur le territoire
donc faites confiance au territoire
interroger les territoires voyez avec
eux et de cela on peut avoir un retour
mais surtout ne voyez pas les
territoires comme un ensemble chaque
territoire et bien spécifique et donc
c'est là où chacun a ce travail à faire
dès lors qu'on a comme je vous disais ce
projet de société ce projet économique
et cet adhésion forte du de la
population il n'y a pas de raison que
que ça se passe mal en suivant d'y aller
de manière progressive très clairement
et on le voit et c'est pour ça je vous
prends aussi l'exemple de Saint-Barth on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui 15 ans après
tout n'est pas fait et je suis pas là
c'est pas c'est pas une posture
politique pour blâmer je même on sort
d'une campagne il y a un travail qui a
été qui a été fait qui a été qui était
bien fait il y a des choses qui ont
avancé mais on voit bien que même en 15
ans et même avec une volonté et bien il
faut que tout le monde soit au tout le
monde soit au travail que tout le monde
soit autour de la table pour que les
choses puissent faire donc il faut
prévoir le projet dans son ensemble il
faut une capacité à s'adapter et à y
aller progressivement étape par étape
mais avec aussi cette simplicité pour
que voilà on n'est pas à repassé par un
ensemble de process administratifs et
compagnie une fois que une fois que le
projet était bien vu voilà qui est qui
est un suivi peut-être aussi ce que nous
n'avons pas et ce qui aurait pu être
imaginé c'est-à-dire avoir des points
d'État aussi régulier
et pas de pas de se dire si ce n'est pas
fait avant telle date on vous enlève le
droit de faire vous retirez une
compétence mais en tout cas avoir un
suivi plus régulier avoir des points
d'État qu'on peut le faire comme on peut
le faire sur toutes sortes de dossiers
pour se dire ok vous territoire de
Saint-Barthélemy on vous a donné des
compétences aujourd'hui ou est-ce que
vous en êtes est-ce que vous avez besoin
de temps pour tel ou telle chose est-ce
que vous avez besoin d'un accompagnement
sur tel ou telle chose je vais reprendre
l'exemple de notre service de pompier ou
ce n'est pas très logique de se dire
voilà vous récupérez la compétence vous
avez le financement ok très bien mais
par contre on adapte ni la formule à la
au besoin du territoire ni on ne vous
donne les cartes en termes de en termes
de gestion RH pour savoir s'il y a à
faire et pour savoir ce qui est
différent de ce que vous faisiez jusqu'à
maintenant donc voilà il faut qu'il y
ait
c'est accompagnement ce suivi en tout
cas qui puisse qu'ils puissent se faire
encore une fois sans donner de bon et de
mauvais points mais simplement de voir
où on en est un petit peu et encore une
fois servir aussi d'exemples aux autres
territoires donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nous discutons pas mal
avec avec Saint-Martin parce que eux par
exemple n'ont pas la compétence
environnement nous nous l'avons donc ils
sont intéressés de voir un petit peu
comment ça fonctionne nous avons la
gestion de notre aéroport là où eux sont
en DSP donc il y a une il y a une
réflexion aussi un échange à ce niveau
là nous avons été sollicités par le
président lostbar au niveau du
département de la Guadeloupe parce que
effectivement eux sont aussi dans une
forte volonté aujourd'hui d'évolution
institutionnelle donc nous sommes tout à
fait disposés à échanger avec avec
chaque territoire à l'inverse je dois
moins recontacter j'oublie son son nom
mais ça mais le président de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon où nous avons
les statuts qui sont très proches donc
de voir un petit peu aussi comment ça se
passe à leur niveau de voir notamment
par exemple sur des sujets très très
annexes la gestion d'une marque
territoire eux ont avancé là où nous
n'avons pas encore fait donc voilà les
territoires peuvent être à même les
changer par en passant par le biais de
délégation comme la vôtre ou en direct
mais il y a un il y a vraiment un
travail de suivi de ses évolutions pour
que les écueils des uns puissent être
évité aux autres
merci merci monsieur le Président je
vais maintenant laisser la parole
peut-être à Lana qui souhaitait
intervenir oui merci monsieur le
Président en tout cas cher collègue
bonjour pour ce que j'ai pas vu monsieur
lancé un ministre des Outre-mer en main
droite c'est bien de ça ça me fait
bon dire un peu quelques années en
arrière peut-être en préambule saluer le
président de Saint-Barth et puis j'ai
une pensée très forte ce soir à notre
collègue sénateur Pierre Magra avec qui
nous avons beaucoup travaillé à rendre
le fameux rapport que nous sommes en
train
d'étudier ici
peut-être suggérer aussi j'aime bien ce
qu'on est en train de faire ce soir et
j'ai un peu pieux je m'adresse en même
temps au président de Saint-Barth et au
président de la délégation outre-mer je
serai je mettrai ma main droite à couper
monsieur
chers collègues l'URL voir tous les
présidents des collectivités mais
devons-nous mais ensemble ça serait bien
de voir tous échanger voici une
entreprise de la collectivité Polynésie
française avec une autonomie pleine qui
s'adresse à vous ce soir je vais pas
anticiper la position de mon Président
il doit disparaître ne serait-ce pour la
fonction mais comme je connais par cœur
mon territoire et puis les derniers
élections législatives ont mis un peu en
exergue quelques frustrations quelques
frustrations et que je retrouve dans
votre intervention monsieur le Président
en Polynésie tout a été transféré à la
collectivité sauf les régaliennes les
pas et comme par hasard aujourd'hui on
parle de la sécurité la police il y a la
police nationale il y a les gendarmes et
puis il y a la police municipale qui
sont des agents communaux en Polynésie
française
Polynésie c'est toujours la table à 3
pieds l'état la collectivité Polynésie
et les communes parce que voilà aussi un
autre acteur très fort
dans le statut de la collectivité ma
question va être mais ça n'engage que
moi en tout mon destin là c'est notre
liste
quel est votre avis monsieur le
Président si on s'alignait tous
sous l'article 74
parce que nous sommes Régis nous par le
74 la Polynésie la Polynésie est régie
c'est-à-dire
avoir toutes les compétences toutes sauf
les regards
et puis à la collectivité tout le reste
comme ça on va plus être embêté
l'urbanisme l'emploi l'éducation
c'est mon c'est ma question c'est une
question rien au gage je pose juste
cette question parce que moi je
partagerai et je vais en finir nous
sommes bien sur notre article 74 par
contre il est encore il y a quelques
lignes un peu à remettre à jour
peut-être en tout cas pour la sénatrice
que je suis il est hors de question
qu'on touche mais peut-être
remettre à jour comme on dit comme c'est
à la mode aussi chez les jeunes faut
remettre à jour un peu vos logiciels par
les temps qui courent voilà ma question
monsieur le Président merci
écoutez oui enfin de tous s'aligner sur
sur l'article 74 moi ça me choquerait
pas spécialement maintenant c'est
toujours pareil tous les bancs de ce
qu'on met exactement dans cet article
encore une fois les territoires sont
tous spécifiques et donc il faut il faut
que les spécifier de chacun puisse être
prise en compte on n'aura pas on n'aura
pas un statut unique mais dès lors qu'on
a un article qui laisse cette cette
souplesse d'adaptation à chaque
territoire
je pense qu'effectivement un seul un
seul suffit évidemment je pense que de
laisser le régalien à l'état c'est une
c'est une base qui est qui est assez
saine et comme je le disais de toute
façon il y a suffisamment de territoires
qui n'ont pas vocation à reprendre ses
compétences maintenant même là sur ce
régalien il faut qu'il y ait une
capacité encore une fois de proximité
avec les territoires donc pour moi si
nous avons tous un ensemble de
compétences auxquelles nous avons accès
que nous laissons le régalien à l'état
et que le régalien et que l'État a son
niveau
s'assure que ce régalien soit proche de
chaque territoire il n'y a pas de il n'y
a pas de souci particulier
je regarde mes collègues pour voir s'il
y a d'autres souhaits et d'intervention
ou de réflexion parce que c'est aussi
oui un vecteur
tu peux penser Victorin ouais voilà
c'est le micro
merci vous allez devoir m'excuser pour
mon retard j'étais en audition en tant
que spécial sur les participations
financières de l'État cette question là
m'intéresse vraiment parce que
la presque dire qu'elle agite les
opinions en Guadeloupe et
j'appelle moi de mes vœux que les
erreurs faites en 2003 on ne les refasse
pas pourquoi problème de confiance à
l'époque en 2003 moi j'étais pour
l'autonomie de Saint-Barthélemy de Saint
Martin et contre l'assemblée unique
telle que elle avait été proposée à 73%
les guadeloupements ont rejetés
l'assemblée unique et si on me repose ça
je dirais non toujours
en revanche
le problème de la compétition continue
de se poser et si la question était
posée telle que le président l'aider la
présenter peut-être que ce serait le
nature à convaincre les opinions
pourquoi suis-je en train de dire ça il
dit que bon l'autonomie c'est une idée
et c'est une pratique et que c'est une
dynamique et ce que l'on fait mieux que
l'État central et bien on peut en
demander la compétence d'exercer la
compétence c'est en fait le mieux placé
pour agir agir donc c'est la seule
zidiarité qui sont dans les textes
européens et qui sont dans les textes de
la Constitution française ça s'appelle
pas comme ça c'est pas écrit comme ça
mais c'est ça donc il y a un problème
comment convaincre les opinions ensuite
ce que fait Saint-Barthélemy depuis 15
ans c'est un dialogue permanent avec
l'état de dire nous prenons ce que vous
ne pouvons mieux faire que vous et à
l'exercice on verra d'ailleurs la
question a été posée est-ce que vous
avez les compétences que vous exercez
aujourd'hui et que vous aimeriez voir
recentraliser bon c'est le cas dans
certains territoires notamment pour le
RSA la Saint-Barthélemy aujourd'hui vu
de l'extérieur c'est une expérience pour
le moment réussie en tout cas vu de la
Guadeloupe de la Martinique c'est une
expérience réussie d'autant plus que et
moi ça m'est arrivé de le dire je sais
pas si c'est toujours actuel que
saint-martinible lundi seul l'une des
seules collectivités à remettre de
l'argent à l'état bon ensuite
apparemment pour nous qui sommes à
l'extérieur tellement sûr d'elle elle
demande à exercer je sais pas si c'est
toujours le cas elle demande d'exercer
la compétence sociale de sécurité
sociale et donc il y a eu un dialogue je
sais pas s'il a abouti pour que créer
cette pièce primaire de sécurité sociale
donc si nous nous inspirons de cette
expérience là en termes de confiance
distillée pour les populations peut-être
qu'on arrivera mieux c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi Guadeloupe je dis une
chose que pour le moment je parle pas
d'évolution statutaire la population ne
comprend pas ça je parle de révision
constitutionnelle que la révision
constitutionnelle met à la disposition
des élus et des populations une coquille
qui permet d'ouvrir le champ des
possibles d'avoir une palette de choix
que l'on va nous élu et parti politique
après proposer à la population si vous
voulez rester éternellement comme ça
vous le pouvez si vous voulez évoluer
avec la gradation que l'on voit dans
l'application de l'article 74 le 74 de
Saint-Martin n'est pas celui de
saint-martin-le-my et n'est pas celui de
la Polynésie donc c'est à géométrie un
peu variable donc à la carte si on
arrive à expliquer ça à la population
que rien ne vous oblige à changer et je
dis ça en passant à certains territoires
et et que rien ne vous oblige non plus à
avoir peur pour dire que c'est
l'indépendance et l'anti-chem de je ne
sais trop quoi je ne sais trop quoi et
donc c'est là que ça m'intéresse et je
pose une question le président Tano a
dit un moment et je demande de je vais
vérifier ça parce que j'apprends là que
seul le prix fait je pense que non je
pense que non corriger
on a eu un sujet ensemble là-dessus mais
c'était pas ça effectivement c'est
l'application latexte extérieur
absolument d'ailleurs ce serait une
asymétrie juridique un peu compliqué
justiciable et une collectivité reste un
jeu sociable je suis pas saisir qui le
tribunal administratif qui le conseille
d'État et quand il s'agit de loi
organique quelque part le Conseil
constitutionnel pour être intéressé bon
les lois de pays c'est autre chose mais
ça pourrait être ça donc c'est une
élément essentiel cette affaire là en
terme d'égalité devant la justice pour
faire adapter les normes ensuite je
demanderai au président l'aider sur dans
les domaines
de compétences de la collectivité
qui détient la police administrative
est-ce que ça a été discuté alors
au-delà des dispositions pénales que
vous pouvez prendre et qui sont pour le
moment difficile à prendre mais dans
l'exécution des mesures que vous
pourriez adopter c'est le préfet pour
bien me faire comprendre je prends un
exemple vous avez
le parc national ou l'agence des 50
pages géométrique chez nous ils n'ont
pas le droit d'avoir des agents
sermentés c'est la police vous avez une
maison faite cinq ans un permis de
construire c'est l'état bon c'est vrai
aussi ici dans l'Hexagone
vous ne pouvez pas démolir la maison
enfin vous pouvez pas exécuter la
décision de justice si le préfet refuse
le concours de la force publique et
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit très souvent il
y a des risques de troubles alors public
et c'est vrai ça peut se comprendre chez
moi à côté de chez moi il y a 6 millions
qui ont été construites du monde sur des
terrains partenariat à d'autres mais la
collectivité n'a le droit d'avoir un
avis donc c'est très souvent médiation
que le maire ou que le Président vous
n'avez pas
dans les champs de compétences la police
administrative alors dans la proposition
faite dans le rapport de la délégation
Stéphane dit Maire propose qu'il y a une
délégation du doigt pénal spécial je
dois pénal mais du droit pénal spécial
et ça c'est peut-être un intérêt qui
peut faire peur mais qui éviterait les
plafonnement évoqués par le président
l'aider et qui pourrait faire ça juste
une je suis trop dans le président mais
juste une chose sur les normes je sais
pas quels sont les habilitations que
vous avez demandé depuis 15 ans ou alors
vous vous êtes contentés et c'est déjà
beaucoup de gérer les transferts de
compétences qui vous ont été attribués
je dirais pas octroyer parce que ça
prend au sens péjoratif mais par exemple
avez-vous une réglementation thermique
des constructions et bien en Guadeloupe
on a payé 5 millions pour cette affaire
là
pourtant on n'est pas dans dans une
forme d'autonomie on a demandé une
habilitation et je veux vous dire
aujourd'hui je suis un peu refroidie sur
ça parce que l'État a tout intérêt
objectivement à vous donner une
habilitation parce qu'elle ne transfère
il ne transfère pas les ressources et
donc sur la consommation d'énergie sur
la formation sur les la réglementation
thermique des constructions à la RTG
qu'on a même exporté après
l'état c'est zéro
et au contraire c'est vous qui payez à
l'état parce que j'ai vu des directions
d'administration centrale venez nous
dire on vous fait l'étude mais vous nous
payez et donc vous avez été un
amendement si le gouvernement est
d'accord coûte moins cher qu'une
habilitation et j'en ai fait 29 de loi
de région ça comme ça et autant en
décret de région et donc l'autonomie a
un coût alors pour le moment je sais pas
si Saint-Barthélemy demande de nouveaux
pouvoirs en matière fiscale mais
aujourd'hui apparemment à cause de
l'économie présentielle je sais pas ce
qui se fait en termes de création de
valeur
artisanales commerciales et agricole ou
de pêche mais à cause d'une forte
fréquentation de l'extérieur il l'a dit
ou d'une présence de communauté qui ont
fait racine là-bas vous avez des
ressources
c'est moins de dotation et que le petit
budget de la mission outre-mer j'ai été
ministre le truc c'était il y a 15 ans
c'était le milliards enfin un peu moins
c'est 2 milliards 4 maintenant je sais
pas combien bon et puis on vous dit mais
il y a 20 ou 24 milliards en effort
budgétaires total de l'État les gens ont
peur moi j'ai eu à discuter avec
Hollande à l'époque pour dire je dis que
la devise de la République liberté
égalité fraternité l'égalité transcende
les statuts la Polynésie et
Wallis-et-Futuna la Nouvelle-Calédonie
ce sont des Français pour le moment et
que l'égalité c'est plus fort que parce
que vous demandez de l'autonomie vous
allez perdre en dotation c'est ça la
tradition française et les gens ont peur
il faut le savoir en disant ouais vous
comprenez
la DGF négative c'était bien ça monsieur
le Président
tous les ans
mais bon voilà on donne 3 millions à
l'état et l'État compte dans tout ça les
trucs de la police de la gendarmerie du
enfin bref tout quoi et donc il y a ça
et peut-être à Saint-Barthélemy où je
sais pas à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
demain ça commence à coûter trop cher à
la collectivité les gens vont peut-être
contester et le statut pour dire que
mais aujourd'hui la solidarité nationale
ne joue plus et donc il faut tenir
compte de ça moi je vois la difficulté
et en Guadeloupe c'est pourquoi certains
élus ne sont pas très clairs et pour
présenter sa pédagogie moi je dis il
s'agit de révision constitutionnelle
rien ne vous oblige à changer
aujourd'hui rester comme vous voulez si
vous voulez mais si demain vous voulez
changer on a une chance extraordinaire
c'est que le président m'a conduit n'a
pas la majorité à lui seul dans le
Parlement il doit conclure avec les
majorité parlementaire et c'est là que
le scénar va jouer à mon sens un rôle
essentiel dans le transport le
transfertisant de trouver les accords et
j'ai dit moi Guadeloupe même si c'est à
minima je vous demande de le prendre si
c'est mieux que ce que nous avons même
si c'est minimaliste même si ça vous
dérange prenez-le après vous devrez
convaincre vos populations pour voter ça
parce que il y a l'obligation de faire
voter donc voilà ce que j'allais dire
vous félicita monsieur le Président
parce que il y a une continuité dans la
confiance qui régnaie à à
Saint-Barthélemy et je vous félicite et
moi ce qui me gêne c'est sur le loi
pénal spécial c'est sur la police
administrative c'est sur les sanctions
c'est sur l'exécution c'est sur
l'accompagnement de l'État sur le
dialogue permanent pour dire aujourd'hui
je vous demande de me donner la sécu
mais parfois ça dure ça dure depuis plus
de 5 ans cette affaire là oui ça ça date
après ça c'est tellement le sujet le
plus sensible parce que contrairement à
d'autres compétences il y a une une
recette qui va avec la avec la sécu et
c'est vrai que forcément ayant un
excédent en terme de sécurité sociale
sur Saint-Barthélemy et bien il faut
trouver la bonne formule pour que pour
que tout le monde y trouve son compte et
c'est là où je disais je sais pas si
vous n’était arrivé tout à l'heure mais
que Saint-Barthélémy a vocation à garder
sa présence et sa participation à
l'effort solidarité nationale après par
rapport à ce que vous disiez il faut
aussi réussir à bien voir que encore une
fois on parle d'autonomie en tout cas
d'une manière générale de compétences la
compétence doit aller avec le
financement et on ne peut pas imaginer
un transfert à moitié où on demanderait
à récupérer une compétence et où l'État
continuerait le faire ou l'inverse dans
lequel vous évoquiez effectivement où
c'est le département qui ouvre la région
je sais pas qui a qui a payé en
Guadeloupe mais il faut qu'il y a une
cohérence entre celui qui fait et celui
qui paye d'une manière générale
je vous propose si c'est possible de
pouvoir terminer cette auditions et pour
résumer peut-être l'intervention de
victorinurel et un sentiment qui nous
habite et que j'ai déjà glissé à
certains collègues qui vont être
auditionnés
cette révision constitue celle quoi
qu'on en dise c'est avant tout d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles
c'est d'ouvrir le champ des possibles et
derrière les calendriers des uns et des
autres doivent se faire dans le respect
des identités propres et des réalités
locales et je pense que je pense que
c'est la voie de la sagesse et je pense
que le Sénat à cette possibilité de
glisser ce message en tout cas de le
porter au côté des collectivités pour
faire en sorte puisque nous sommes avant
tout vous représenter bien évidemment
faire en sorte que ce message-là soit
porté mais il a été déjà en cas du
rapport de Michel dans toutes les
interventions qu'il a pu faire par le
passé et on va continuer à porter cette
cette parole faire en sorte que nous
puissions vous accompagner dans les
évolutions possibles
avec quand même je le dis je le répète
un message de une précaution d'usage du
ministre que j'ai nous avons entendu en
audition d'autres jours sur la
nécessaire création de valeur et ce
n'est qu'à cette seule raison que nous
modifierons les statuts non nous disons
que ça n'est pas incompatible d'ouvrir
le champ des possibles et de permettre
d'autres aspects que la seule création
de valeur
une remarque sur ce que tu viens de dire
j'ai entendu aussi notre ministre et
[Musique]
je sens pas la volonté exprimer par le
Président de la République à l'Élysée je
le dis très clairement et je sais que
aussi manier la langue de bois quand il
le faut et là lorsqu'on me parle
uniquement de création de valeur mais en
même temps on verra les travaux c'est
d'abord un plan d'attendre mars alors
que la les travaux de révision continue
je ne sens pas encore la volonté
politique de ce gouvernement de nous y
mettre je le dis très clairement je le
dirai d'ailleurs
mais je vais lui dirai on ne sent pas
cette affirmation alors moi j'aime pas
me cacher derrière des mots où on est
d'accord on n'est pas d'accord on met
des limites où on ne limit pas on
éclaire pour le moment ce n'est pas
clair j'avoue je le lui dirai
mais je pense qu'on sera plusieurs à le
lui dire chez Victorin et puis surtout
la parole donnée par président de la
République devant tous les
parlementaires ultramarins je pense
qu'on était tous à l'entendre et le
message du président a été très clair
alors derrière effectivement nous
annonce la création de groupe de travail
menée par le gouvernement on a bien
compris c'est une manière de temporiser
une neutraliser en tout cas le Sénat à
son plan de charge le président Larcher
a installé le rouleau de travail
décentralisation et le c'est n'importe
quoi évidemment cette parole là bien
évidemment auprès du gouvernement
je vous propose si vous en êtes d'accord
Micheline si tu si tu veux rajouter un
mode conclusion peut-être
je voulais remercier le président de la
collectivité Xavier je voudrais
remercier aussi tous mes collègues qui
ont incité à cette audition et qui a été
fort instructive et qui j'espère a pu
permettre aussi de danser les débats et
d'éclairer sur les autres auditions à
venir
merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs bonne fin de soirée merci
beaucoup à vous bonne fin de journée au
revoir